[MUSIC]
There's a great anecdote about
the very first photograph taken
of Earth from the
vantage point of space.
The idea was that
this photograph
occasioned a profound shift in
our understanding of ourselves.
You see, for the first
time in human history
we could look back at our
planet in its entirety
and see the big picture.
This provided an
ontological awakening.
It changed our
story, our narrative.
It upgraded our self image.
it expanded our consciousness.
New maps for new
realities, as they say.
Astronauts in orbit call this
experience the Overview Effect,
aa a boundary shattering
sense of revelation and global
interconnectedness.
Where we shake off
our petty differences
and emerge with a sense
of global responsibility,
global consciousness,
and global citizenship.
Carl Sagan's famous Pale Blue
Dot film echoed the same idea.
From the vantage
point of space there
are no lines dividing nations,
no geographical subdivisions,
no flags, or racial divides,
or disputed territory.
There is only Earth.
A single celestial
body teeming with life.
The womb in which we dwell.
Yet, the fact is our
historically myopic point
of view, most certainly
are limited perspective,
has resulted in much animosity.
We have, all too often,
organized ourselves
into competing hostile tribes.
Subjugating each other
for land and resources.
And misrepresenting
the big picture
into a story of
borders, subdivisions,
and dividing lines.
Too much hostility, not
enough empathy and compassion.
Cultural differences, religion,
tribes, nation, race, these
are creative expressions
and variations that
should and could be celebrated.
Instead they become
symbols that are all
too often used to create
suffocating boundaries.
And they are increasingly
ill conceived
to address the challenges of a
hyper-connected global world.
As advancements in
technology and information
enable greater mobility of
ideas, goods, and people,
the role of the physical
border is shifting
and due for an upgrade.
Conflicts remain,
and too many people
are restricted access to
the increasingly fluid means
of migration,
transportation, and movement.
Migration has always
been a defining factor
of the human experience.
Migration has, and continues to
touch, all nations, cultures,
and regions, all
peoples on the planet.
Migration has been
the seed at the heart
of thriving societies.
Accelerating the dissemination
of knowledge and ideas.
Restricting migration
is ultimately
like restricting
the flow of ideas.
In much the same way that
we don't tolerate censorship
or book burning,
we might consider
the ways in which restricting
the free movement of people
can be equally punishing to
the idea of human flourishing.
The desire to become a
global citizen is human.
We all have it, and we
all share the same goals
for safety, comfort, and
prosperity for our family.
Some are fortunate enough
to be able to invest
in a second residence
and citizenship.
While others are forced to
seek asylum for their survival.
Being a global citizen
is also about the strong
and the wealthy helping
the weak and the poor.
As we saw with the Global
Citizen Tax Initiative.
Boarder disputes, conflict
zones, armed borders, these
are things that persist
and need to be addressed.
We need a new story, a new
lens with which to address
these inconsistencies.
We need to scale up,
to unleash a truly
global citizenry, exchanging
ideas, beliefs, goods,
and services.
It has been said that
empathy rarely extends
beyond our line of sight.
So, perhaps it is by
extending our gaze,
using marvelous new storytelling
tools like virtual reality,
that we can bridge divisions
and bring worlds together.
Ushering in a form
of radical empathy
to see the other as ourselves.
Where boundaries are
dissolved and compassionate
reins supreme.
Massive transformation
of conscious.
A software up-grade for mankind.
Birthing a new kind
of global citizen.
We can do this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]